alex is in Louisiana
hi Alex how are you hey Dave hey Rachel
how are y'all I'm good
great how can we help so here's my
situation
about four years ago my parents bought a
duplex for my brother and I from the
trust they had for us they paid for the
house in cash and we pay them back every
month with interest just like a normal
mortgage but I recently got married I
got married in November and my husband
and I are now looking to either throw
more money at the mortgage or saved for
the next house I was just wondering if
you had any advice and my brother and I
you know it's one mortgage we just each
pay our parents half of it every month
if I were to pay more money towards the
mortgage do you have any advice as to
how to keep track of that for is it the
property value in our area is going way
up to so I don't know if it would be
better to just save money on the sides
or whenever we eventually need more
rooms and sell another home we are
living in is what is a duplex
oh you're living in this duplex yes sir
I live on one side my brother lives on
the other and your new husband moved in
with you obviously he did yes he didn't
have a property he did not have a
property even though that point your
brother live in the other side he does a
lot of together yes yeah okay well this
is a well-intentioned gift that it has a
lot of potential trouble right because
at the time they did the gift or the
process they felt like they were helping
you and you guys were excited both of
you were single you both had a place to
live and you know anybody with your
parents but the downside is as your life
start getting more
complicated and one of you wants to get
out of this or in your case maybe pay it
down it's not structured to where you
can okay and so I would be so radical as
to say owing your parents money is a bad
idea because the borrower slave to the
lender and Thanksgiving dinner tastes
different even though they're very sweet
and they're very know boiling they're
very and well-intentioned it's still in
the air being a partner with your
brother while you're married is really
tough and living next door and living in
a situation that we're kind of splitting
it but legally we haven't and
financially we haven't right I probably
am NOT going to get my way in this but
if you if you and your brother and your
mom and dad were sitting in front of me
in a coaching session I would suggest
you sell it what you expect it yeah but
I appreciate that and alex is your
brother is he happy on his side of it
like I mean like is he wanting out is
there like a team thing that you guys
have the same common interests or is he
good no I mean to be honest with you so
he's the older brother we're only two
years apart but I just feel like I feel
like the older sibling a lot and before
I even got married I mean I just feel
like I take care of everything and I'm
just good at that not nature so so I
mean I think he's content I actually had
started a conversation about what it
would take to buy him out we're going
over very well it didn't go over very
well though so like I just stopped my
dad I told my dad I was like you know I
I think I either want to buy him out or
sell it and he's like well you know
realize it's your brother you know like
you're gonna have to like that yeah but
you don't have to you know knock down a
duplex with your brother to be nice to
your brother right I just um I don't
know I feel a little stuck I you were
I'm impressed you were all
ready ahead of me you already were
talking about selling it before you
called because you were feeling the
incongruence the you're feeling the the
weirdness that's in the air and it's
pulling at you from about four different
ways and you know and so and you weren't
liking it already yeah the only thing
that makes it hard is I love this house
like we are in the hot spot in New
Orleans that's been growing so quickly
the property value okay there's a duplex
three words down that's on the market
for over two hundred thousand dollars
more than we paid for our house four
years ago so you could put a hundred
thousand dollars in each of your pockets
and go on your merry way I yeah so is
that what you're suggesting I mean
because I just don't like yeah I'm in a
financial position to throw extra money
on it but if it can't be document well
the problem is if you do that and your
brother doesn't there's all kinds of
stuff I mean you know there's just no
you know you could pay it down but you'd
have to separate the note with your
parents between your brother has a note
and you have a note will be the only way
to do that and they would probably be
willing to restructure and then let you
pay your note off however the property
still has a lien on it because he has
not paid his half off and I'm out anyway
yeah exactly and so somewhere along the
lines something's going to happen here
so I think that this is a again I think
everybody wanted to do a good thing and
if you get out of it before it causes
all kinds of problems it'll turn out to
be a good thing but the best way for
this to be a blessing for everyone is to
put this house on the market I and then
go get you something if you want to stay
in the same neighborhood that's fine
take your hundred thousand dollars and
go buy you and get a mortgage that's not
with your mom and dad and pay it off and
your new husband as fast as you possibly
can and that's exactly what I would do
it's exactly the plan it's so hard
though because I feel like with families
and again like you said parents there's
such good intention there's such
goodwill
I've got hope but you have to think
long-term and in that situation you know
when you're that was four years ago well
mom and dad are going well I'm getting
the interest which is more than I would
get over at the bank right and I'm help
my kids out but they don't think about
the fact that the borrower slave to the
lender and it changes that it changes
the tone the tenor the look tone field
of the relationship and I don't care how
sweet the person is you are still their
master they are still your slave and how
well-intentioned they are and so we do
not loan people money especially people
that we love and you know if they want
to help you and they've got some extra
money one give you some money that's
perfectly fine I've done that and I'll
do it again
but but I'm not gonna loan someone money
because it's changes the relationship
the old joke is if you loan your
brother-in-law two hundred dollars and
he never speaks to you again was it
worth it you know because you know it's
gonna screw up the relation right right
I mean you think about the friend in the
coffee-break room and you loan them 50
bucks for payday and it what's it do it
there were the nicest and everybody was
happy together and all of a sudden their
whole personality their body language
changes everything and and that happens
to varying degrees but that's the the
process and so yeah yeah that that's the
plan
and I I hate it and you're just got to
be very gentle and it has nothing to do
with you it's I got married and I want
to have my own space and I want to have
my own life and this interwoven thing
with my parents and my brother doesn't
feel healthy and I just I love you guys
and I don't want anything to come
between us and so you couch it that way
and say we're selling it yeah we're
selling it or you're buying me out or
I'm buying you out more than three
doesn't matter you choose and it hasn't
got anything to do with I'm mad at you
it's I don't like where I am and I have
a say here I am half owner in this thing
and oh by the way you don't even have a
partnership agreement that gives you the
right to force the sale so technically
if they everybody bows up you'd have to
go to court to force it which would be a
real pain obviously uh what a mess